Continental Tire Coach's Corner
brought to you by Continental Tire you
see the Continental Tire at sporting
venues across the United States proud
sponsor of EMSA racing Major League
Soccer college basketball Continentals
premium products available at leading
independent tire dealers car dealers
mass retail companies across North
America for more information visit
Continental Tire com Tata Nano tire for
what you do former college coach now a
great analyst for CBS sports Rick
Neuheisel here in the man cave good to
see you again you're looking good I am
feeling good it is great to see the
dinettes how's everybody happy holidays
and obviously great to be in your
company again a couple of things to dive
into what is Oregon getting with Willie
Taggart
it's a great question you know he's he's
a horrible guy he was the running back
coach at Stanford for gym and he played
for Jim's dad Jack Harbaugh at Western
Kentucky and so he believes in the power
he's gonna run downhill it's gonna all
be about but everything that you see in
the Jim Harbaugh way of doing things is
is echoed with Willie Taggart so it'll
be interesting to have him come back
into a league that they are tribal at
least prior to this season was Sanford
you know because that's still David Shaw
who was also a hard ball guy so you're
gonna have to two guys in that
conference that were definitely
influenced by the Harbaugh way of doing
things and we'll see how it all turns
out are you surprised at that higher I
am i I was surprised that they made the
move on Mark Helfrich now certainly the
performance this year probably merited a
change but the the problem is who are
you gonna get you know as I looked
around the landscape in the what Willie
Taggart will have to do and do quickly
because Stanford's a completely
different recruiting animal which is his
experience on the west coast is he's
gonna have to get a staff that
understands California
what Oregon did wrong in my estimation
and if you watch them play this year and
you saw some of the matchups
athletically with their guys when Ronald
Jones came through the line of scrimmage
as their running back for USC and alson
a safety couldn't even lay a hand
it's an evaluation problem they missed
on a lot of recruits and if you look at
their roster there's they're all from
all over the country Pennsylvania
Florida Tennessee Georgia Oregon was in
the air too far and should have been
down in California like my old buddy
Nick Aliotti was down there scouring the
Northern California area and getting
guys like Patrick John and TJ Ward and
those guys who are still playing on
Sundays
those guys are missing right now for
Oregon so Willie's just got to get back
into the film room make sure they're
doing great evaluations because they've
got a lot to recruit too they're in
Eugene how do you win an interview
because you've you've been in where you
haven't gotten a job and you've been in
when you have well yeah the difference
well it's it's kind of just magnetism
it's late it's like meeting a girl you
know you see a girl in a lunchroom and
all sudden their the conversation flows
you're not thinking about what next to
say it's it's very much the same it's a
relationship and now with search firms
involved you have to kind of have a
little information as to what who you're
gonna be talking with but but ultimately
I think rather than trying to impress
the committee or impress the people I
think you just go and say what you
believe is the right thing to do going
forward and if it jives then it's a it's
a great marriage rather than saying
things that they want to hear and then
now having to tailor what you really
want to do to what you said you would do
how do you seek out another job while
doing a job during the season it's my
it's my biggest problem with college
football right now I think that we have
the wherewithal to move recruiting back
and get it pushed back past the dead
period which now goes through the
coaches Convention which is just after
the national championship game get a few
more weekends in February and let's stop
poaching each other's coaches as soon as
the regular season is over and allow
guys to finish their seasons and we
everything we do in the college football
world as coaches is tell our kids to
finish whether it's finished a drill
whether it's finish a class whether it's
finished your degree we try to get them
to finish and that we don't you know as
coaches it's very hypocritical and we
could fix it we just need to change some
rules talking to Rick new house
CBS sports college football analyst did
the committee get it right with the
final four I think they did I still
struggle I'm an old schooler you know
the Big Ten Champion is Penn State they
beat Ohio State I'm okay with oh hi Penn
State going in Ohio State being home if
it was reverse trick and it was Ohio
State who beat Penn State and won the
Big Ten title there's no argument here
the likelihood is you're exactly right
yeah yeah if you just find reverse their
resume it's the same thing we said two
years ago when Baylor and TCU were
fighting to get in if those were
Oklahoma in Texas would somebody have
jumped past them you know we're in an
era now this is only third-year of
playoffs so I guess we're it's much ado
about very little because we don't have
much of a sample size but when you're
sitting there looking and seeing that we
the SEC East has never been in the ACC
Coastal has never been in the Big Ten
West has never been in the pac-12 South
has never been in and now the Big 12's
been out two of the three years we're
we're it's we've got this envy for these
unique brands in college football that
is always gonna be the case as long as
we say best teams in we're always gonna
think they're the best we need to go
most deserving everybody from my
generation to the younger kids
understand champions get in I just think
if you took away the school and you said
look look at the resume here and I know
it the the human element is factored in
here there is oh hi oh state didn't
deserve to be in the Final Four last
year even though I thought that they
were a great team I I thought the other
teams had they had proven themselves but
Ohio State is a brand now doesn't you
know they proved to be the best team but
you have to earn that right to be in the
Final Four
one of two things was gonna happen for
the first time in the college football
playoff this year either we were gonna
have a two loss team that would have
been Penn State as a champion from the
big ten or we were going to have a non
champion in and that was Ohio State and
they went with you know the beautiful
school the the tradition to scarlet and
gray I mean it's it was one of those
deals and not that Penn State doesn't
have a fantastic brand but right now
there's there's the Blue Bloods they're
Alabama
Mich
again Ohio State they wanted Michigan in
there oh they wanted they wanted
Michigan and an Alabama to square off
the nick saban Jim Harbaugh would have
been too spicy for well no they wanted
Ohio State Michigan to play one more -
no question no question about it there
they wanted find a way to get old khaki
pants and shot in this deal Wow old
khaki pants us see if us he played
Alabama now in Dallas neutral site right
what happened well it wouldn't be 52 to
6 but but but it but it would be still
an Alabama win listen I was down in
Atlanta the CBS did it we did it on site
our studio show from this from the
sideline they had 16 points with - 7
yards of offense
Alabama's defense is just off the charts
I'm standing there watching them now
I've been on some sidelines and I know
what they look like
that is a unique unique defense that you
can't run the ball you can't run the
ball on them Florida in two championship
go rounds has a net total of 15 rushing
yards in two games they were 17 carries
for 0 yards this last time are they a
great team or a great defense they're a
great defense Lane Kiffin usually tries
to experiment early in the game gets
nothing and then goes down to pounding
and realizing that very little can go
wrong when you just run down hill with
with a great offensive line hurts is a
unique athlete I think they utilize his
legs more as they go forward I don't
think they had to and to get to where
they are now is Lane Kiffin toxic as a
head coach but desirable still as an
assistant I don't know that yeah you
know I think that's probably unfair but
it's hard for me to say nice things
about a guy that beat me 52 nothing rub
it in well yeah there's no question did
you say they did not know you know
chance that's my job to stop him right
it's my job but but but the bottom line
is he he has done a great job at Alabama
he's you know three playoff appearances
that you're a head coach they're guys
who are meant to be assistant coaches
and that's what he's going to have to
Billy charlie weis with you and I were
on the interviewing committee those
would be the questions are you ready to
kind of be gracious with alums are you
really to spend time are you is that
gonna be important to you because at
Alabama it wasn't important for him to
do anything other than roll out and make
sure that offense was ready to score
points but and play along with that
defense anywhere else the Houston I
guess is where he's being considered
right now he's gonna have to recruit and
he's gonna have to be ingratiating to
all those alums that think houston
should take the next step into a power
five conference and he's going to have
to be the face of the program and it
can't just be X's and O's it's more than
that more hats have to be worn as the
head coach in college football why would
he be offensive coordinator in Alabama
and then go to LSU to be offensive
coordinator maybe slash you know
assistant head coach or I don't know
what well Idol but it might be a
financial thing you know it may be an
increase of pay okay it's a relationship
thing you know I don't know what it's
like to work with Nick Saban but it
didn't in the early season it didn't
look like it was a lot of fun for him
but and at oshrin and here are old
buddies I will certainly give him more
autonomy on that side of the ball all
right we'll come back with Rick we had a
big question discussion yesterday the
greatness of Drew Brees is Drew Brees a
better quarterback than Brett Favre
better quarterback than Dan Marino save
your answer Rick we'll be back right
after this
Buffaloes back I guess how about that
been a long time oh sad story about
rashon salaam huh now the here's the
former Heisman Trophy winner running
back at Colorado when you first heard
that he had taken his life right would
you think you know I had dinner with
rashon three years ago I was out to
watch them practice and Bill Merle the
athletic director who hired me back in
1995 and I were sitting down having
dinner rashon came over and Dave platy
you know day from sports information so
we were all sitting there and I thought
wow Sean was doing really well you know
there had been some concern you know the
NFL career didn't last as long as maybe
you'd like and but I thought he was
doing really well and I spoke to TJ
Cunningham who was a teammate of his
yesterday and he said you know what
there was some bouts with depression and
so forth and in situations like this I
think we all wish we would have reached
out we would have known more and all
that kind of stuff but all I can do is
think about you know I recruited him I
tried to get him to come to UCLA and he
ends up going to Colorado and I was a
young coach at the time I said why cut
why Colorado and he said it felt like
family and and I just don't know if he
felt the hey that's where the family was
you know late in his life now this is a
guest well we wondered yeah most of us
concussion maybe anything concussion
related that you take your life now we
think that when you have a former player
right who takes his life and we thought
concussion it was it was interesting you
know when you're the Heisman Trophy
winner you're put on a pedestal and
sometimes that pedestal is not
comfortable you know you you've come and
you're supposed to be around
universities and be an ambassador and so
forth and that doesn't necessarily feel
like your personality and so who knows
what that played into it I just
obviously it's tragic we all wish we
could have been done more and been there
but what I'll always remember about the
guy and he was a 2000 yard rushing
everyone not the runs he was fabulous
and not the screen pass he made our
double screen like magic but on the Hail
Mary if you ever watched the Hail Mary
again watched the block
rashon Salaam puts on to give Cordell
that extra time to do the couple crow
hops and launch a ball 73 yards in there
he came back and literally depleted a
Wolverine defensive lineman being
cleated him and that's the kind of kid
he was it was all about team it was all
about family he was he was a great young
man I'm just sorry to have to have this
news a topic yesterday on the program
we're all in on Drew Brees that it
he gets left out of the blood tears race
yeah right so Paul II had a bombshell he
said that he would take Drew Brees his
career over Dan Marino's I think that's
right okay I think that's right well he
won a Super Bowl yes right dan dan yeah
it's not a walk off we still have Dan
got two ones and I and I think you know
so much was expected of Dan Marino
because of the way the career started
yeah and it just never quite came to
fruition now the yards were there and so
forth but the winds and the
Championships never quite
on line with what we imagined was the
talent breeze we've always kind of
thought as the little train that could
you know he's the six footer I mean when
you meet him he's my size yeah you know
and I'm going man this guy he's throwing
for these many yards and this in this
environment and when he thought the
career was over at San Diego with the
shoulder injury and he gets resurrected
there in New Orleans and takes that deal
and to see him in the middle of the of
the huddle you know when they're leaving
that the I just think the guy is really
remarkable I coached against him in the
in the Rose Bowl
you know Purdue in Washington and so the
two teams go to Disneyland and my kids
were three four years old at the time
and Drew Brees came up and said hello to
my kids my kids thought he walked on
water so I've always been a breeze fan
but I would take that career given the
numbers given the the way he's embraced
the city of the cities embraced him and
the championship what about Brees Red
far I so I coached for the Ravens and
I'm a quarterback guy I always admire
quarterbacks and for me Brett Favre was
too loose to gunslinger not enough
discipline within the offense did he
make a lot of plays just laissez-faire
yes he did and they were sensational and
we'll always remember him as that kind
of guy but in terms of a structure and
getting what you want from him on every
down basis I would take brief because
Brees knows what's going on the defense
Brees to me we all say the term back
shoulder right and back shoulder almost
most people always assume is the ball
it's on the sideline a guy going down
and throwing it back behind in the
corner can't make a play Brees took back
shoulder to every throw on the field the
four verticals were the two guys are
running seems he put back shoulder on
that on a corner route when now we're
playing people were vice in a what we
call bracket coverage on a slot receiver
running a corner he threw back shoulders
inside you know was the inverse of a
back shoulder Brees found ways he threw
people open better than anybody I can
remember the quarterback now in college
that you'd buy stock in it for the NFL
well I think deshaun Watson I think he's
really really special now what do you do
with Lamar
Jackson when he comes down just keep
coaching the heck out of that drop back
pass stuff and I thought Bob Petrino did
a marvelous job of that and from year 1
to year 2 we saw him CBS did the game
Louisville played Auburn in the opener
and he played remember two years ago and
was I mean obviously a great athlete but
nowhere close to a quarterback in the
spring game I'm told they did nothing
but throw I think he had 54 passes in
their spring game and did well
conceptually remember Bobby Petrino
coached the Falcons he's got NFL
concepts and understands how to put
patterns together Lamar Jackson is not a
running quarterback that takes advantage
play-action wise adjust what you're
gonna do to stop the running game they
actually drop back and throw the ball
and I think another year of that because
he's got armed talent yeah I think he's
gonna be sensational and this high spin
thing is is fascinating certainly he
fumbled Iseman but I think he fell on
his own fumble even because when you
really break down the numbers he's had
30 touchdown passes in 21 rushing
touchdowns and he ran for fifteen
hundred yards Watson was fantastic and
he's the only quarterback in the history
of the college football playoff to take
his team twice but he had 15
interceptions and if you just make the
field goal North Carolina State makes
the field goal we're not having this
conversation it's just and that was a 33
yard chip shot I think Lamar Jackson was
off the charts he just hurdled the guy
at the wrong time it should have been
week 12 when he jumped over the syracuse
defender what do you think it should
bril tempers marvelous athlete and it's
interesting you know as I watched him
later in the season he's not as hip he's
a little stiff in the hips that's why
he's moved to the linebacker and I think
he'll end up being a balk safety kind of
like kam chancellor they'll get playing
for the the legion of boom will look for
Jabril peppers but he's but when he was
running somebody down had to stop and
twist you could see that's why he's come
closer to the box but obviously a gifted
guy and I think what makes him special
great athleticism but you see him in the
middle of the huddle you see his
leadership you see his want to compete
it's it's part of the fiber of what's
made Michigan special again he's Rick
Neuheisel
and normally Rick would bring his guitar
but those days are done we miss those
those days I'm bringing those back butts
but but there's nothing to keep me from
being a poet a poet there once was a man
named Patrick there was worried he was
becoming geriatric but he found some
pets now known as Dennett's and now he's
considered theatric restyle I still like
the guitar the guitar will come back
yeah if you could be Paul McCartney or
Mick Jagger ooh
McCartney you can I say I was at a house
in Long Island and I think Jimmy
Buffett's house on Long Island you were
there
no I was not there I don't get those
kind you get invited but I had a friend
who was there he sent me the video and
it was Paul McCartney playing Hey Jude
with Jimmy Buffett in the band and it
was just the coral reef first and
everybody was out there just this is his
backyard
in his in and McCartney just kind of
hanging out I go that guy's got cool now
that doesn't mean Mick Jagger's not cool
but but McCartney if you could be Paul
McCartney or Jill Montana Joe was great
you know Joe could do Joe Joe look down
Joe could look down and throw it right
there to Roger Craig without ever
changing this hips and just then Roger
Craig did a first down because I'm
looking at Jerry Rice and there's Roger
Craig just going that's what now for the
I said I'm a quarterback guy that's cool
but I'm still going McCartney I mean
think about being in the Beatles I know
what a run how about Montana or Brady is
there ever been a better player than Tom
Brady seriously better player I mean
seriously that guy is this angelic
assassin he is unbelievable the way he
prepares and in every eye it's a little
bit tainted because of Belichick but now
but but we would say the same thing
about Walsh in Montana how about if you
had to have one vote for the Hall of
Fame and you have to vote for Belichick
or Brady I'm going with the player I'm
going with Brady Montana or
Walsh I'm going with the player Montana
hope you uh get back into coaching
I hope so too I do I hope you get a
chance I miss it it but I'm enjoying
doing what I'm doing because then you
can play the guitar for us if you get
back under coach cigs actually right
that's the only reason why coach again
you bring the guitar one of our favorite
guests he's Rick Neuheisel CBS sports
college football analyst the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience
[Music]